Speaker 1: Also interesting yesterday, CNN
was able to get an interview with President
Zelensky in his bunker.
He's been in a bunker for some period of time
and occasionally exiting the bunker to record
videos and do different things that we have
seen.
CNN's Matthew Chance spoke with Zelensky in
the bunker about what's going on with negotiations
and other things, and it is incredible to
see
Speaker 3: you send your delegation to meet
the Russians for talks.
Did anything substantial come out of that?
Is there any hope as the world watches for
diplomacy?
They decided they decided to begin to speak
about the situation and I wanted I really
wanted and I told them.
You have to speak.
First of all, you everybody has to stop, stop
fighting and to go to that points from where
it is was beginning.
Yes, it began five today, six, six days ago.
Yes, I think there are principal things you
can.
Do it, and that is a very important moment
if you'll do this and if those side is ready,
it means that they are ready for the peace.
Speaker 1: The the level of I've never been
like a big Zelensky fan or anything like it,
but the level of poise that he is exhibiting
from a bunker separated from his family as
bombs are dropping, shelling is happening
all over the country.
It is just incredible.
Speaker 3: If they don't, really, it means
that you are just, you know, just wasting
time.
Do you think you're wasting your time or do
you think they're ready?
We'll see.
Speaker 1: Just I mean, it is it is unbelievable
what is taking place right now and the question
around the so-called negotiations is an important
question.
We sort of just very casually talked about,
well, what is it Russia would want in such
negotiations?
I imagine Russia would want to officially
kind of see Ukraine give up on Crimea and
probably give up on the Donetsk and Luhansk
regions.
That's that.
That's probably something Russia would want.
Is that something Ukraine would be willing
to give?
It's hard to imagine.
On the other hand, I would imagine that Ukraine
would want Russia to accept that if Ukraine
joins Naito or if Ukraine joins the EU, it
would not be opposed by Russia or seen as
a sign of aggression or as a justification
for aggression by Russia.
And it's very hard to imagine that that's
something that Russia would accept as well.
So they talk about negotiations.
It's in a practical sense, very difficult
to imagine what sort of agreement there could
be that would be satisfactory to both sides.
But that's why there is such a thing as professional
diplomacy and professional negotiators.
We will continue seeing that there's sort
of the two tracks.
There's the we are looking at doing some negotiation
on the border with Belarus, and there's at
some point Putin's going to make his play
for Kiev.
And that could be at any time.
And it's not obvious that Ukrainian forces
and volunteers are going to be able to repel
the Russian forces, so the next 24 48 hours
could be key.
We're going to take a quick break.
The clips from that Zelensky interview, which
is very much worth watching, will be on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show.